the real housewives of dubai is finally
here let's go around the room why did
each one of you want to sign yourselves
up for a reality tv show so i wanted to
sign up because since i was a young girl
i've always wanted to be seen so i was
really really excited about it like why
wouldn't i sign for it it's like epic
you know
it's like the dream you know i've been
in fashion my whole entire life so this
was like a better stepping stone for me
so i love it i was like kind of worried
about doing it because i've never done
reality tv i don't know if that's the
path i want to take in life but then as
i slept on it like the idea i was like
okay i know there's a lot of stereotype
in the western world about arab women
and how they live their life and the
middle east so to me it's just a window
for me to talk to the world about how we
are and who we are and how things are
here so we can kill all the stereotypes
and lisa this is not your first reality
tv rodeo
college hill
people will be binging it as soon as
they see you back on their screens
let me tell y'all how milan just tried
to put me out with that fake ass
[Laughter]
why did you want to come back and do
more reality tv because college hill was
an experience for you it really was
it was quite an experience you know and
it was over a decade ago and there was
no social media there's a whole
different ball game a whole different
era but i didn't say yes immediately but
i thought it would be a great
opportunity for me to inspire women who
are like me young female entrepreneurs
i've always said if you can dream it you
can achieve it so it was just a
no-brainer for me to be honest it's a
great platform to show exactly who i am
was there a lesson you took away from
your first experience when you were just
milan you were not lisa milan you were
just milan is there a lesson you took on
and applied to this
ten years later you know what actually
yeah i did there was a lot you know the
18 year old lisa and the 33 year old
lisa is not the same person you know
i've grown so much i think i'm a more
rational person i i listen better i just
apply so many skills that i learned from
college hail and i stay off the blog
very important lesson for everybody in
this room don't play with me i'm not the
one caroline stanberry i'm going to
start with you why was now the time to
reintroduce reality tv cameras to your
life i mean so many reasons i've changed
city i've changed man i've changed life
i mean i've had a complete three what is
it like 180 i'm like just a different
person caroline brooks why did you want
to sign yourself up for reality tv i
didn't want to sign myself up i was
approached okay and
when i was approached for it i was like
yeah i'll do it you know i think i was
at a point in my life where
maybe if you asked me a few years ago i
wouldn't have but i'm at a point in my
life where i was like all right i'm
comfortable with this i can open the
doors to my life and let people in i do
live a pretty interesting life you know
i can understand why they wanted me on
the show yeah as saying the casting
director reached out and to be honest
with you rice i think i manifested this
i've like been watching housewives since
it first came out and when i stepped
foot into dubai which was back in 2011
actually i visited before i always told
my husband the only thing dubai is
missing is the housewives and i feel
like i kind of just manifested that and
here i am
[Music]
now brooks you also have some friction
with lisa and ion what's it about
the friction that i had
had you know where we're in a better
place with lisa and ayan
was surrounding caroline's stanberry
nice friendship that's what it stemmed
from so it did stem from the fact that
caroline and i get along really well and
that may have not sat well with certain
people
but it's their problem not mine i have a
lot of love for lisa and chanel but i
get to pick my friends we're not in high
school what is it about her that the two
of you don't gel with for me personally
i just don't like that i don't know who
i'm gonna get that's my issue
and then one and she likes to piss me
off and she likes to lie about things
towards me and that i do not like so in
that way she i find it like she just
likes to find a way to anger me
intentionally so she can injure me at
the end of the day we are a real group
of friends right yeah
sometimes we don't it just depends on
you know where the wind blows in the
desert i'm her friend and sometimes
she's my enemy so it's like that oh my
god why are you lying again i made a
comment that you invented it was
important yes
who's the potster of this group then
caroline brooks caroline how do you feel
about that reputation i think it's
fitting
i i throw a little shade but i love
everyone i i don't want to hurt anyone i
just you know i have one too many drinks
sometimes and things come out wrong but
i say sorry every time you know liquor
is truth serum sometimes so maybe it's
not out wrong maybe it's just the truth
we say she drops a bomb she goes oops
he runs literally runs drops it leaves
it and runs but as i run i'm talking a
lot of trash everyone drops bombs every
now and then right but i think caroline
brooks is consistent yes definitely
yeah okay well we're all fit we're all
we're all been there done that for
t-shirts
[Laughter]
everyone's taking a ride on the brook
roller coaster okay
i don't always say sorry sometimes i
mean it like sometimes it actually takes
a couple of glasses of something on
blanc for me to actually tell the girl
how i feel about her i'm not nina like
i'm speaking generally right but when i
apologize when you see that in the
season about things that i know i was
wrong for i really mean it but when you
don't hear an apology from me every word
that i said to that woman i meant it
whether i had too many glasses of wine
or not i meant i stand ten toes down on
what i say that's it okay
any of you reach out or get reached out
to from housewives from other cities
with any advice
i think we all did phaedra who i've been
family friends with for over a decade
basically told me to buckle up it's
gonna be a very very crazy ride and you
said you gotta ride along with me for a
little bit because we have you to thank
for bringing her back to our screens
don't we indeed
indeed and i'm so excited for all of the
bravo fans to see not only
manufacturer's relationship but to see
why phaedra came to dubai give me the
tea honey i'm very thirsty today
i missed you the first person that
reached out for me was dolores from new
jersey oh wow yeah so she gave me a lot
of advice and then jensha i literally
speak to her almost every day she's so
real and tells me how it is and she
introduced me to all the cast members of
salt lake city on first time when i was
in new york so i thought that was
amazing i was star struck i was crazy
and then i met kenya moore on face time
with lisa milan and i met phaedra so
you've met you've had your own personal
bravo con essentially you've met all the
housewives
i haven't met old i want to meet kim
kyle's sister oh kim richards okay you
you like a controversial kooky lady is
what i'm picking up oh absolutely
because i'm one of the cookies you know
[Music]
you